Hello everyone. I'm John from VAI and
I'm very happy to here to talk about our
latest model series uh J 4.6 series. And
let's jump right in.
First uh I will introduce the GM series
model.
Gen 4.6 Six is not our first open source
model since 2022 starting from the very
first G30B.
We have been quite serious about open
source our work. Over the years, we have
released a whole family of models such
as chat gem 6p for language model and
the code for vision understanding code
view for image generation and the video
for video generation and the very uh
many more across the different domains
and on this side you can see a map of
our open source model so far and include
the different color such as the white is
for the language model the z GM series
and the pink for the multi mode
understanding such as the code VM and
now it's called GMV and the green one is
for image generation and the yellow is
for video generation.
Uh 2025 is our open source year of and
in this year we added even more models
including the GM4 0414 dense model
including like 9B and 32B and the GM4.5
G4.6 M O series model which is actually
our first MO models family. So up to now
we have released over 65 module in total
and the closed platform like hing face
monoscope and others we have already
passed 100 million downloads. If you
search for the GM or video on GitHub you
will find 105 1,500 community project
really top of them and is much a
communitydriven ecosystem. Now
let's move to uh GE 4.6.
Uh I will introduce it now.
So G 4.6 is our latest flagship model or
many public benchmark especially in math
and coding. G 4.6 shows a clear game
over GM 4.5.
It also output opensource model release
in the same period like dipstick version
3.2.
and even beat this commercial model such
as the cloud SOS 4 on several
benchmarks.
Of course, if we compare to the clock
4.5, there still be a noticeable uh
noticeable gap. So, we are not coming
with everything, but we're getting close
and close.
uh but what makes us especially happy is
here is um arena uh this benchmark
uh this is uh which is closer to real
user preference and on element arena gem
4.6 say it's time for number one
together with GPD5 and the cost cross
storage 4.5 and it's the only open
source model here and so I'm very happy
appreciate and I want to thank our
developer who try to who try our model
and votes for it so let's move to the CC
bench
so beside the user benchmark we also
build our own data set called the CC
bench Here we want to text agent style
coding in real world not just iso lore
problem. So we built a agent coding text
platform based on the cloud code and on
top of that we create CCB version 1.1.
So compared with version one version one
uh the new version added 22 hard coding
task and we statistically evaluate coco
sonets a consonate 4 and g 4.5 the kim
K2 and the versions 3.1 terminus
in total citybench have 74 tasks is
covering the front end development and
internal tool development in the data
analyze and also So algorithm
implementation. So for every model we
record the full agent trader query the
planning st the call and code adds and
execution the fully open source this
benchmark. So you can check all the link
later uh below in the hiring phase and
JM 4.6 made a clear jump over June 4.5
and over uh over performance is called
to call 4 with about 68.6% 6% win rate
while being significant better than
under open source baseline. So uh where
does the performance come from? A lot of
uh let's talk about GM 4.6 training
and in this uh we will start from the
data v training design. First part is
the general pre-training. So we start
with about 15 billion uh 15 trillion
tokens of the generate proposal data
includes web page books uh acupedia and
multilang multi uh multilingual content
and so on. So this stage is about
building a strong allrounder best model.
The contest then here is 4,000 tokens
and the next step is called the
reasoning continue training. So on top
of that base with about 7 trillion token
of extra code and reasoning data. So
it's part of this part of this counts
for a high quality open source reports
and another part is math science and
context program with four stepbystep
reasoning.
Then we come to the mid training. So we
move to ripple label codes uh include
that multiple files issues and pull
request and the difference from the same
project and all these packed into one
long contains and the goal is to teach
the model to following the close file
and understand the chains and to also
understand the pro square chains and
read the real project structure end to
end. So at this stage we stand the
content to 32,000
and the model can basically see the key
file of a medium size ripple on one
shot.
Then is a synetic reasoning data. We
added about 500 billion token of synetic
reasoning data. So it cover map science
and algorithm with experience thinking
trace. So it's mean the lay of the
groundwork of future agent behavior like
breaking down the task refle uh
reflecting on the mistake and doing
longchain reasoning. Uh the next step is
the long content and agent data. Uh
finally we use about 100 billion token
of a long content and agent data. Here
the secret then is now pushed further to
180 uh 20 uh 128,000 for GM 4.6 is
200,000. So the model can handle four
documents and the whole data uh code
base and very long chart at the same
time we feed lots of agent chery. So
include that multi-step two calls the
search and the code execution extra. So
uh in this space improve the model long
content capability and the aging
capability.
Also in this slide we introduce slide
and it's our reinforcement learning
framework and based on eston inference
stack uh in practice uh we design in
house training framework here and we
also open source it uh we found that the
different task need very different
system design
for short reasoning task like the math
or the code completion. So the best
setup is clocked uh with the average
agriculture. So we train inference in
the same GPU. So after one batch update
wave. So the next batch immediately
sample for the latest policy. the
screens the most of GPU memory and
compute and but for agent task and for
example the real software engineering uh
usually have many steps like for example
open the browser and hit uh backend API
and for the external response um extra
so if we force every worker to stay in
the sameness the forces the get dragged
down by the service field and GPU
So in slide we decide he agriculture to
support both uh
and secret model. If you look at the
diagramraph the blue part is meatron
batch training engine w for data buffer
and opposite ways and the green pause is
high throughout intervention coaster. So
with a routine of dispatch request and
in the middle the data buffer act like
the share nist systems. So one side
connect training and other side
differential agent environments for
regular reinforcement learning cost. We
keep training and in uh inference on the
same GPU pool using with a sim mode and
dynamic sampling instant update and the
maximum throughputs. Once we switch
reach to complete agent task we move to
a decouple and synchroniz mode. So the
row outside port talks directly to real
environments and just regenerate
tractory and write them into the buffer
and then the training side consume the
data in own space up the model and uh
periodically push new way.
So the nice thing is even if some tasks
super slow they don't block the whole
training pipeline. So on top of that we
have done a branch of efficiency
optimization
[Music]
like the main chain still run flow 16 uh
stability but after each policy update
we do blockwise FDA cronization on the
latest ways and send FPA version through
our work. So the most expensive part the
data generation and running FDA with
much higher output while training this
keep BF BF16 precision. So in practice
we will get the benefit both accuracy
and speed in this framework.
Now let's zoom in reasonal ISO and this
slide with some plots. So the first one
is about the two-stage curriculum we
use. We don't change all the fixed data
set from start to finish. Instead, we
use a two-stage difficulty curriculum.
In stage one, we use medium difficulty
problem. In each batch, some arrive in
some room. So, the rewards have various
in the grinding are meaningful. All the
model get stronger with which you
extremely hard problem in stage two. But
with 512 samples, you can still
occasionally get a correct solution. So
you can see on the pause the blue curve
is our method after switching to hard
problem the curve is keep going up.
However use the uh median difficulty the
way uh is not on the red curve. The next
picture is about a single stage
reinforcement learning as 64,000 tokens.
Some previous works such as multi-stage
reason uh reinforcement.
for is that uh for example is uh 16 then
32 then 48 and finally 6 64 but we found
that for model that is already been
trained with 64,000 token uh SFT those
shorter IO strange actually make you
forget it long content ability so
average upper listings and the finals
64k token stage can't fully recover the
loss
So the red curve here is our approach.
We start directly with 40 uh 64,000
uh token and train in one single stage
re is clearly outperform than the blue
middle multi-stage curve. Uh
the the picture below is about the code.
So on the left bottom we complain two
ways of committing the laws for code. So
the blue one is classic sequence means
loss is sequence has one loss value and
the red one is our token w means loss
which average over token instead of
sequence. The token w version converts
faster and most steadily and it reduce
the chances to generate very short
template answer just to get the rewards.
And the right you can see the data.
uh we do get a science reinforcement
learning on GPQA demons and the
messaging almost opposite of more data
is better. The red curve red curve is
trained only the small set of expert
verify but high quality multiple choice
question and the blue curve use mixed
quality data. So this result that a
small blood clean data set gives much
better performance. So for scientific
reasoning data quality really matters
more than raw size.
After talking about J 4.6 language model
we move to the multimodel.
J 4.5
supports the both image and video
understanding. It is our latest visual
understanding model and go and on
grounding and the image understanding
benchmark it shows strong performance
and the clear advantages over other open
source model release around the same
time.
So agriculturally you have the three
main PS here
the one is a version transforming coord
and then it's like with MLP projector
and the finally is 4.5 base model at the
coordinates. So we're trying hard to
keep the virtual input as original as
possible. So the model can see the image
negative resolution and accept ratio
instead of focusing everything into a
fixed square. So this matter a lot of us
screenshot and also long vertical image
and the pawn point slides. So looking
for the video we also insert a time
index token after each time basically
telling model this is the friend C and
this is the second T and they help it
understand the temporal order and
reience which is crucial for action
understanding and step by step uh
producer.
Uh we also use a method uh as we
researched before co uh in coke agent.
Now the GUI agent capability is also
support on GM 4.5 B. So you can like uh
it can also help you to control the
computer and also like the website to
control uh you can use the mouse or the
keyboard touching and to communicate
with your uh browser also computer or
mobile environments.
So how to use G 4.6 or G 4.5 V model.
The first one is using a open source
weight. Uh as we know this both these
tool is open source. So you can use the
echelon or v or other framework to
inference it. Uh along with the weights
on the release day we already had
achelon and the vlm integrated ready and
we also work with many third party open
source frameworks like the llama factory
or ms swift. So thank you to this
community there you have you can choose
uh any that framework you want and to
try our model but
the GM uh GM 4.6 model is a large model
with like more than 35 uh 355
billion parameter. So if you don't have
that 100 or like and other uh GPUs
there's an easier way to uh use our
model. So in this slide we show the
deploy uh command of using Helon or the
VLM. Here
the next slide uh we can use the GM on
the Z. AI uh Z.AI AI. This is a website
and you can try your uh directly
and you can use the writing code you can
using to generate powerpoints and so on.
And in this uh demo is uh using
one command to write the Google
searching in our dat
uh demo. So you can just uh communicate
with it
and also GM is famous in coding
capability.
So we also provides the GM coding plan
which connect GM with tools and other
plugins that cloud code or other coding
developer uh develop tools and to
provide a very strong coding assistant
experience. We also have a short demo
video that uh show how to replace Yodi
model in a cocoa livea with gem 4.6 here
and you can uh see the you can watch
this on YouTube
then is the uh our community activity
beyond today talk where regularly host
events both online and offline. So
whenever we release a new model we
usually run a several community session
afterwards as the first one there is AMA
in the Reddit and we also have some uh
we also have some offline and onsite uh
techn uh tech technology sharing so you
can join us
the final uh slide is some important
link you may to know uh is about website
as I as I mentioned mentioned before to
try GM model as ZAI and also our API on
here then we also provide GM 4.6 six
technical uh technical board and J4.5
tech reports. Uh you can check it and
you want to join our community here is
the discord link and also the GitHub
link is below with the open source model
including the readme to how to deploy on
the open source method. That's all of
today. Thank you very much.